this program is brought to you by Emory
University
well two days ago we welcomed into the
world three little boys that were
triplets they are the sons of a very
nice lady miss Salinas and what's
interesting about Miss salinas is her
first pregnancy she had a single teen
pregnancy her second pregnancy she had
twins and this being her third pregnancy
what a surprise she had triplets
triplets are very rare spontaneously
conceived twins are about two to three
percent but to to see a young lady that
has twins and triplets I've never seen
that before and none of my colleagues
have and I've even googled it and we
haven't found one document documented
case like this before all three are
doing very well there in our neonatal
ICU step-down unit which is managed by
dr. Crites and they're doing very well
one was born at six pounds in six pounds
four ounces six pounds even and four
pound 8 ounces they are all doing very
well breathing normally they're starting
to eat and they probably will be able to
go home in very short time well I just
wanted to say that I practice at more
than one hospital and I felt that Emery
midtown was the place for miscellaneous
to deliver her baby because of the
excellent care that she I knew that she
would receive from the labor and
delivery staff postpartum NICU and
anesthesia emory healthcare to me is the
best place to deliver your baby in
Atlanta
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University